This building in Hamburg, Germany, is entirely powered by algae.
Inside these glass panels is a green liquid...
...in which you can see the bubbles rising to the surface.
This is the result of having a bioreactor built into the facade,...
...which heats the 15 flats in the building.
The motor is microalgae, and the principle is photosynthesis.
Heat is produced here in this facade by the bioreactors,...
...then it is stored here before being redistributed.
The heat is used to power the central systems supplying heating and hot water.
The building, therefore, effectively heats itself.
Laura is one of the people who live here.
Her balcony looks like an aquarium with all the algae growing there.
Also, this passive construction means that the building...
...maintains a comfortable interior temperature without heating.